daniel blach
bonsoir ma chère à l'iss bonsoir j'ai
réussi mon michel dinet drucker rooney -
périphérie alice la crue et cas pas été
tendre pour super dupont mais
apparemment vous paraissait détendu
oui je suis détendu mon chéri chéri tu
peux moral non parce que physiquement je
suis plutôt attendu 10 au moins dans ma
carrière j'ai eu plus de lifting que de
rappel mon chéri chéri
tiens regarde par exemple à caen je
serre les fesses et les pocket is ferme
c'est extraordinaire non moi je avec ce
qui mentiraient je ne suis fait un sac à
main d'ailleurs ma chère à l'iss oui
mais non michel launay lorsque vous êtes
venu d'en changer il n'y a pas très
longtemps on m'avait dit que vous étiez
très branché avec les jeunes que tout
allait bien et que certains jeunes vous
trouver non seulement beaucoup de charme
et certains sex-appeal oui j'ai du
succès avec les antiquaires et
brocanteurs mais aussi avec les les
jeunes oui j'ai du sex-appeal là c'est
que sa fille louis fans ne citons pas de
marque à la télévision mon truc
alice la télé le théâtre doit beaucoup
vous êtes tapas deux monstres sacrés
sont fait plaisir et je suis un monstre
ça tu fais bien de le dire - chérie
chéri mais c'est vrai les directeurs de
théâtre mais doivent beaucoup car avec
moi ils font des économies de chauffage
d'électricité puisqu'ils ferment à
l'entracte généralement sauf quand je
sers les les grands auteurs que mais
comment s'appelle-t-il cet angle l
acquis qui meurt tout le temps je
clapote de jeux panam j'expire winch et
william shakespeare oui avec j'expire
j'ai pas pu éviter le flou mais avec
jacques sogepa éviter le filet
naturaliste
mais charlie comme tous les ans et que
tu me plais vraiment drucker ou non je
te trouve aussi viril que lino ventura
moi qui vous ai vu dans les coulisses
mâché réalise comme toutes les grandes
tragédiennes vous respectez le texte oui
oui on peut dire mon chéri que abba
gardner liste et la chérie chéri
composent moi je me décompose quelques
j'ai tout fait dans ma carrière chazot
le cg j'ai fait du doublage de dessins
animés maintenant j'ai des saints à
réanimer plutôt fun les enfants sont
fous de moi en france souvent ils me
jettent des pierres dans la rue quand je
passe aux etats-unis écrit après moi iti
ma chère à l'iss oui pour réussir
oui mon truc transinne vite comédienne
il faut une silhouette un certain galbe
en plus de son talent d'acteur mais
malheureusement je n'ai pas le physique
de claudia cardinale mais j'ai une
poitrine extraordinaire j'ai un seul
plus grands kloet moins cher et c'est
mon premier mari avait l'habitude de
s'endormir en le prenant dans sa main il
dormait dans l'autre chambre au bout du
couloir mais évidemment c'est enfin cela
dit mes confrères trouve que j'aidais
robert obscène chirac
après une fin d'année 82 mouvementée
vous allez prendre un peu de repos
ben tu sais mon truc à onex mon chéri
chéri j'avais toujours à pâques à rome
n'est ce pas et je vais également aller
dans une vieille propriété de famille
nous l'avons depuis cinq générations
c'est moi qui l'ait fait bâtir au bord
du loch ness mon chéri en question et
alice quels sont vos projets pour 83
mais tu sais j'ai déjà donné mon corps à
la science elle a refusé alors je vais
réussir mais faire engager pour une
grande série télévisée mon chéri chéri
je sais la vedette on verra pas tout la
france défigurée
alice sapritch thierry dol et or ces
rallyes
aline bonjour je sais je sais que vous
aimez les jeunes les jeunes auteurs
compositeurs et moi chérie chéri witham
et les jeunes oui bien on va applaudir
maintenant un jeune auteur compositeur
qui a déjà marqué l'année 82 je dois
vous pouvez cristiano n'est c'est ça
hervé cristiani ses positions